Salut comme dirait Orelsan:
"Aujourd'hui on revient aux basiques." C'est-à-dire qu'on va faire un master class pour apprendre à multipliant ensemble de tête et hyper rapidement
des chiffres jusqu'à 20x20.
Genre 17x19 par exemple, et on va pas s'arrêter là. Pourquoi ? Je vais vous le dire pourquoi puisque déjà moi ça faisait longtemps que
j'étais pas dans les vidéos. [imite Sarko] Parce qu'il y a une méthode qui existe pour faire ça avec des chiffres quand jusqu'à 100x100.
Genre 67x97 comme ça de tête.
Ces astuces là, ces techniques là, je les connaissais pas, mais comme vous savez je me forme en permanence, et je les ai découvertes il y a
quelques mois par un pote qui s'appelle David, qui a à peu près les mêmes passions chelous que moi, et qui a ouvert une chaîne l'année
dernière qui s'appelle "Mnemonaute". Donc c'est parti et juste avant de commencer, j'en profite aussi pour vous remercier vous êtes déjà 200 à avoir
réservé pour le spectacle à l'Olympia de l'année prochaine, soit déjà
10% de la salle, c'est très très gros 10% de la salle, c'est cool ! Donc les meilleurs sièges commencent à partir. Je vous invite à
réserver dès que vous pouvez si vous savez que vous voulez venir.
Déjà parce que vous aurez les places les moins chères et vous pourrez choisir le placement.
Vous avez ça en description. Alors la première question que vous posez à la normale c'est: Est-ce que c'est vraiment aussi simple que ça
de pouvoir calculer jusqu'à 100x100 comme ça de tête ? Je pose la question à
David, est-ce que c'est aussi simple que ça ? -Bonjour Fabien et merci et oui les tables de multiplications ça en a vraiment
impressionné plus d'un, je dirais même presque dégoûté des mathématiques c'est le début du moment où on s'est dit
"je vais être nul en maths", et en vrai c'est pas si compliqué et il y a des vraies astuces pour rendre ça hyper simple.
Bon c'est vrai je vous rassure quand il m'a expliqué cette méthode là, je l'ai comprise
instantanément et j'ai pu le reproduire tout de suite. Donc je vais te laisser David nous expliquer comment on fait de manière basique
et après moi je vous réexpliquerai de manière un peu plus imagée". -Donc l'astuce qu'on va voir aujourd'hui
c'est par exemple des multiplications pour les nombres entre 10 et 20, parce que les tables jusqu'à 9 jusqu'à 10 comme ça les faire c'est facile !
Mais un 17x15 tu fais comment ? Alors le 17x15
Il faut le rendre assez visuel et on verra que c'est pas si
impressionnant qu'on le croit. Et moi je les pose comme ça: en général je mets le plus grand en haut et le plus petit en bas.
Donc j'ai le 17x15 et je vais rendre les choses très simple, c'est-à-dire que la multiplication par 10 on le sait elle est facile.
Je prends mon 15 et j'enlève tout ce qu'il faut pour arriver à 10. Donc là c'est 5,
et je le monte en haut, donc 17+5=22. Ok on est d'accord c'est interdit dans les
multiplications normalement faire des additions, soustractions entre les produits.
Tu vas voir où je vais en venir. Donc j'ai un 22 en haut et j'ai un 10 en bas,
22x10 ?
220. Ça c'était pas très compliqué, et il nous reste les deux unités de nos deux produits: le 7 et le 5 qu'on va multiplier entre eux.
Et ça nous donne 7x5=35.
Je prends mon 35, je prends mon 220,
255 ! 17x15=255.
Et vous verrez que vous saurez faire des calculs assez fous en un rien de temps.
Alors comme ça peut-être ça vous paraît flou pour la première fois mais je vais récapituler les étapes elles sont très simples: vous avez
les deux chiffres entre 10 et 20 que vous les multipliez ensemble.
Vous mettez dans votre tête ou sur le papier peut-être pour vous entraîner une fois, le plus haut au dessus. On fait ça par
exemple pour 16x18, on va mettre le 18 au dessus et le 16 en dessous dans notre tête.
Deuxième étape on va transférer les unités du plus faible au nombre le plus fort, donc le 6 de 16
on va l'envoyer sur le 18, ce qui va nous donner 24x10.
Deuxième étape bis, parce que franchement entre vous et moi on va pas dire que c'est une troisième étape,
on va finir cette multiplication du 24x10 ça fait 240.
Ça, ça va, c'est un truc que vous maîtrisez, je le sais ! Donc la troisième étape ça va être de
multiplier ensemble les deux unités de départ.
Donc le 8 et le 6. 6x8 ça fait 48. Ça c'est sûr que dès qu'on veut faire du calcul de tête faut connaître nos tables de base. Bien, dans
notre cerveau on a donc le 48 qui traînasse et le 240. On va additionner les 2.
48 et 240 ça fait 288. Et 16x18, si vous vérifiez, ça fait bien 288.
Si on compte les petites étapes, ça se fait en 4 ou 5 étapes, mais réellement dans votre cerveau ça se fait en trois phases.
Le transfert des unités pour faire une multiplication par 10, la multiplication des unités ensemble et l'addition des deux.
C'est tout ! C'est aussi simple que ça. Est-ce que franchement c'est pas brillant ?
Moi je trouve que c'est brillant ! J'ai eu un kiff quand j'ai découvert ça.
Ben alors une fois que j'ai su faire ça, et je vous assure que si vous le faites
deux trois quatre cinq fois vous êtes capable de le faire pour toute votre vie
instantanément. Ça le fait ! J'ai demandé à David, s'il n'y avait pas une méthode pour aller jusqu'à 100x100. Apparemment je n'étais pas le premier
à lui demander et donc il a aussi une méthode pour ça.
-Evidemment tu le sais j'ai des internautes des
followers sur YouTube qui me poussent toujours à aller plus loin, c'est bien le 10x20 mais va plus loin, est-ce que tu
peux nous emmener au 100x100 de façon facile ? Alors oui c'est possible, je me muni d'un outil et si tu prends un
x85, tu vas voir que juste le fait de l'avoir comme ça de visu... 6x8=48, 5x4=20
ensuite j'ai 6x5...
et 4x8=32, 32+30=62, 48, 20 ça doit être 5440 !
On pourra vérifier, mais ça va assez vite. La méthode je ne sais pas si tu la connaissais...  -Alors là je pense que vous êtes comme
moi, la première fois qu'il m'a fait ça, j'ai compris ce qu'il faisait au fur à mesure, ce qu'il faisait. Mais j'ai pas compris
comment il a assemblé tout ça pour en faire un résultat final.
Là en plus il est sympa, il vous l'a fait sur le papier. Je vous l'explique rapidement, ne cherchez pas à retenir mais je vous explique juste
le concept rapidement. Imaginons qu'on veuille multiplier ensemble par exemple 53x81, dans un premier temps on va multiplier
ensemble les dizaines donc 5x8 ça fait 40, et les unités 3x1 ça fait 3. On va soit écrire ça, ou mieux,
l'imaginer dans notre tête: qu'il y a 40 d'un côté et 3 de l'autre.
Ensuite en parallèle de ça, on va faire un truc alors vraiment ne cherchez pas le retenir, c'est juste pour vous expliquer mais la phrase
en elle-même va être très compliquée. On va faire l'addition du produit de la première dizaine
avec la deuxième unité, plus la première unité
avec la deuxième dizaine. Ok donc en clair on va faire 5x1+ 3x8.
Ce qui nous donne: 29 et ce 29 là, on va l'insérer dans le trou qu'on avait laissé entre le 40 et le 3.
Sachant qu'il y a que l'unité qu'on est dans le trou, parce que la dizaine on va l'associer au 0 du 40.
Soit 4293. Alors là oui je vous entends dire et vous avez raison: "Oui c'est trop compliqué, quand tu as expliqué on a rien compris !"
C'est normal. On a rien compris parce que David sur sa chaîne il l'a vraiment expliqué détaillé, je vais pas lui prendre son travail,
si vous voulez vraiment connaître toutes les étapes pour ça, vous allez sur la chaîne de David,
Mnemonaute et vous avez toute l'explication avec tous les cas de figure. D'ailleurs petite question en passant à David:
moi je fais des recherches en permanence je m'intéresse à tout ce qui existe comme technique et comme nouvelle technique également,
j'essaie également de trouver les miennes mais j'aimerais bien savoir quels sont tes sources en fait pour trouver ce genre de choses.
Alors les astuces, je ne les ai pas inventées, en tout cas pas toutes et j'ai des vraies sources.
Alors les sources, je dirais que ça vient des gens comme toi parce que toi aussi tu en donnes dans tes vidéos, dans son livre, "Mon Cerveau
Est Extraordinaire" et puis une vraie source pour moi ça a été Arthur Benjamin.
Il a fait une série de DVD et de vidéos sur le net qui sont en anglais et qui donne des supers astuces.
Et ce qui est intéressant c'est que la source elle ça peut être pour vous aussi, si vous aussi vous avez des petites astuces comme ça
en maths des petits trucs qui permettent de faire des
skill en plus des petits hack rapides de calcul mental, vous pouvez nous les mettre dans le... dans les commentaires,
je lirai ça avec intérêt même si ça vous paraît juste une toute petite astuce toute bête,
l'idée c'est de les compiler et je pense que j'en referai une vidéo avec toutes vos astuces, à vous, en prenant des scripts de votre commentaire,
et en les commentant ou en les améliorant peut-être si parfois je connais des trucs qui permettent d'aller encore plus loin.
Et tant que vous y êtes n'oubliez pas de mettre un pouce bleu à cette vidéo, parce qu'un pouce, plus un pouce, plus un pouce
plus un pouce, ça fait pleins de pouces et ça c'est plutôt cool !
David de la chaîne les "Mnémonaute" ça fait plus de 3 ou 4 ans je crois qu'on se connaît, ça se trouve c'est plus et dans
ces cas là il va râler ! Comme je le disais il a ouvert sa chaîne et un petit peu plus d'un an,
si vous aimez tout mes Master Class, mes astuces, il y a de grandes chances que vous appréciez le travail de David.
Je te laisse présenter ta chaîne en quelques secondes d'ailleurs. -Donc Fabien j'anime une chaîne sur YouTube qui s'appelle "Mnémonaute" qui en vrai
s'adresse à tous ceux qui se sont dit un jour dans leur vie: "Alors moi je suis nul en multiplication,
en maths, en anglais, je ne sais pas retenir les prénoms, les numéros de téléphone
mon numéro de carte bleue, j'oublie, la géographie, c'est pas mon fort..."
Et bien c'est un petit peu ça que j'apporte un Mnémonaute c'est toutes ses clés
parce que si j'avais eu en étant en collège ou au lycée toutes les méthodes que je connais aujourd'hui,
et bien ma scolarité elle aurait rien eu à voir avec ça. Voilà peuple des internet ! Vous savez tout ! Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo,
prenez quelques secondes pour souffler, pour vous entraîner,
ça vaut le coup parce que au-delà de faire poser la calculatrice, ce genre de méthode ça permet d'améliorer sa visualisation et de reformer son
cerveau traitements multiples et rapides, et ce bénéfice là il est bien au-delà
ensuite du calcul mental. N'oubliez pas de soutenir la chaîne et de vous abonner à très bientôt !
Ciao !
Alors ce premier rond sur ma droite, si tu fais un clic dessus, ça t'abonnes à ma chaîne et il y a une personne sur
deux qui regardent les vidéos qui pas abonné, alors c'est l'occasion de le faire ! On n'hésite pas et l'autre rond qui est juste à côté
c'est la fameuse chaîne de Mnémonaute de David qui a fait cette vidéo avec moi merci beaucoup à lui !
Et puis on va pas se mentir un grand merci à vous !